حسنًا
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
[موسيقى
] قال رئيس شرطة دوريات ماريو بول
إن مستشفى ميداني بالقرب منك
تعرضت لأعنف غارات جوية روسية ،
ولكن هل يمكنك إخبارنا بمدى سوء ذلك ،
نعم كانت ضربة عنيفة بالأمس
على إصابة مباشرة بالمستشفى الميداني
الموجود بالداخل
اعتبارًا من مصنع الصلب
وتم إصابة غرفة العمليات مباشرة
وتم تدمير جميع المعدات الجراحية
وكل ما هو ضروري لإجراء
الجراحة ، لذا
لا يمكننا الآن معالجة جرحانا نحن على
وجه الخصوص  الذين أصيبوا
بشظايا وأعيرة نارية سيدي تقول إن
هناك أكثر من 500 شخص مصاب
في مصنع الحديد من العسكريين
والمدنيين حتى قبل قصف هذا
المستشفى الميداني ، هل هناك كادر طبي
قادر على علاجهم
نحن نعتني بالجرحى أه
صحيح  الآن مع أي أدوات لدينا ،
لدينا مسعفون عسكريون لدينا وهم
يستخدمون كل مهارة
لديهم لرعاية
الجرحى والآن ليس لدينا أي أدوات.
أدوات gical ولكن لدينا
بعض الأساسيات ولكننا أيضًا في
حاجة ماسة إلى الأدوية ، ولم يتبق لدينا أي
دواء تقريبًا